بعد رحله امتدت لنحو عقدين في الملاعب
الاوروبيه رونالدو يسجل مشاركتهم الاولى
في الدوري السعودي بقميص النصر امام
الاتفاق هي مشاركه رقم 952 مع الانديه
وخامس دوري يخوض منافساته بعد البرتغال
والانجليزي والاسباني وحتى الاقامه شارك
رونالدو في لقاء كاملا وحمل اشاره قياده
الفريق في المباراه التي انتهت في هدف
نظيف سجله اللاعب البرازيلي اندرسكا
الظهور الاول رونالدو خطف انذار الجماهير
بعدما تاجلت مشاركته لمبارتين بسبب عقوبه
ايقاف الانضباطيه التي لحقت به من اخر
مشاركه له مع مانشستر يونايتد النصر يتصدر
الدوري بفارق نقطه عن الهلال لكن مع
مباراه اقل ويلعب رونالدو مباراته المقبله
امام الاتحاد في نصف نهائي كاس السوبر